[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la salud con más
Romero sala Buenos días para usted
Buenos días Ángela vamos a comenzar esta
sección hablando de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud de que ya clausuró
su asamblea general hubo acuerdos pero
también hubo desacuerdos como suele
pasar en este tipo de encuentros no en
este caso reúne 194 países todos los que
conforman la Organización Mundial de la
Salud y la idea es que busquen las guías
que tomen decisiones resoluciones que
guíen un poco el accionar de la OMS
durante el siguiente año vamos a empezar
por los puntos en los que sí hubo hubo
acuerdos por ejemplo se llegó una
resolución sobre el impacto de los
químicos de los plásticos en los
residuos sobre la salud humana se pidió
básicamente que se pueda pues compaginar
Buscar más información y se haga más
investigación sobre los impactos
precisamente eso de la salud en la salud
de este tipo de elementos también ayudar
se pide especialmente a los países
vulnerables a poder evaluar estos golpes
de la salud que sobre la salud que tiene
la polución por ejemplo de los
pesticidas que usan en sus cultivos y
que gracias a esa información que se
pueda recabar Durante este tiempo se
llega a un acuerdo vinculante para
disminuir o para intentar paliar los
impactos sobre la salud que tienen en
los desechos y los residuos no esto es
especialmente importante porque en este
momento también durante esta semana se
está debatiendo un tratado internacional
para buscar terminar la polución de los
plásticos particularmente y esas
conversaciones se están dando en el seno
de la uned que es el programa Ambiental
de la ONU nosotros trajimos algunas
cifras para contextualizar un poco el
problema del que estamos hablando cada
año se producen 460 millones de
toneladas de plástico de las cuales se
recicla solo el 10% el 25% termina
contaminando el medio ambiente sin
ningún tipo de gestión de residuos y el
resto termina o incinerada o en
basureros Y eso es un que además se
prevé que vaya más Y hay muchos estudios
que podemos detallar en el futuro que
hablan de cómo estos plásticos por
ejemplo interrumpen procesos endocrinos
de Cómo pueden afectar la salud
cardiovascular Especialmente los
microplásticos entre muchísimas
muchísimas otras afectaciones y sin
embargo mar está muy enredado el tema de
un acuerdo global para limitar el uso de
plástico cualquier acuerdo global
siempre en verdad está muy enredado
porque poner de acuerdo a tantas
personas y también las que implican el
sector privado es muy complejo y
especialmente cuando hablamos de medio
ambiente tampoco nos digamos mentiras
Otra de las resoluciones que se aprobó
en defensa de la salud de las
poblaciones tiene que ver con indígenas
Así es vamos a escuchar parte del
comunicado de esta resolución para para
saber de qué estamos hablando
los pueblos indígenas Aunque representan
grupos y comunidades diversas en general
tienen una esperanza de vida
considerablemente más baja que las
poblaciones no indígenas También tienen
una mayor prevalencia de varias
enfermedades y condiciones de salud
adversas incluyendo la diabetes la
mortalidad materna e infantil y la
desnutrición básicamente lo que pide
esta resolución es que haya un plan de
acción global diseñado para 2026 y que
este plan se haga en consulta con las
comunidades indígenas que incluya
también formar personas de estas
poblaciones indígenas para que sean
trabajadores de la salud que tengan en
cuenta las cosmovisiones particulares de
cada comunidad y los conocimientos
particulares de estas poblaciones y
recordemos que eso son poblaciones
relegadas normalmente en lo
socioeconómico No nada priorizadas Por
los gobiernos y por los estados y
también con mucho menos acceso
normalmente a infraestructura sanitaria
que permita tratamientos que permita
diagnósticos que permita prevención de
la salud así que bueno una de las ideas
que también que ha surgido entonces en
esta asamblea es tratar de paliar estas
desigualdades que existen entre
comunidades indígenas y comunidades no
indígenas y sin embargo es el pan de
cada día mar en este tipo de encuentros
los temas geopolíticos Por supuesto
Siempre salen a flote como lo hicieron
esta vez por supuesto no no iba a ser
menos un el primer ejemplo es que no se
incluyó a Taiwán que pide estar siempre
en estos órganos de la OMS y por los
conflictos que tienen con china que lo
reclama como parte de su territorio al
final no se acepta pero en este caso el
protagonista fue la guerra en Ucrania
uno de los puntos que se debatió y que
se terminó aprobando es una resolución
que condena abiertamente a Rusia por la
invasión en Ucrania y particularmente le
pide que cese todos los ataques sobre
infraestructura y sobre personal
sanitario por supuesto la delegación
rusa votó en contra de esta propuesta de
hecho hizo su propia resolución de la
mano de Siria también en condena sobre
cualquier tipo de ataque en cualquier
sobre infraestructura sanitaria sin
mencionar particularmente el conflicto
que protagoniza también en Ucrania y
esto pues viene especialmente a cuenta
porque esta misma semana la OMS publicó
sus cifras sobre las consecuencias que
está teniendo esta invasión rusa sobre
Ucrania ha registrado en 15 meses de
guerra más de 1000 ataques en todo lo
que se ha infraestructura o personal de
la Salud La mayoría como vemos como
decíamos es sobre la infraestructura
casi 900 pero también hay sobre el
transporte sobre los almacenes y
especialmente dolorosos sobre el propio
personal sanitario son 72 ataques sobre
personal sanitario se han cobrado la
vida además de estos ataques de 101
personas tanto pacientes como
trabajadores de la salud y todo esto lo
estamos diciendo por supuesto sin tener
en cuenta las consecuencias indirectas
al final que trae que traen estas
guerras sobre la salud de las personas
entonces bueno esto por supuesto también
fue uno de los temas que guió estas
conversaciones en la asamblea que
terminó esta semana
finalmente la OMS seguirá debatiendo
otro tema que es bien importante y es el
tratado Para futuras pandemias en eso
como siempre no vamos avanzando es lo
que decíamos que suele costar estos
acuerdos globales Aunque la OMS lo busca
desde que empezó el covid-19 no un
tratado que sea vinculante para para
garantizar una respuesta internacional
coordinada el director general de la OMS
lo mencionó también en su discurso de
cierre de la asamblea
generaty Esta es una oportunidad que
debemos tomar Somos la generación que
vivió la pandemia de Kobe 19 Así que
somos la generación que debe aprender
las lecciones que nos enseñó y hacer los
cambios que protejan las futuras
generaciones
safer particularmente debemos trabajar
para contrarrestar la desinformación
sobre el acuerdo que circula en varios
estados la idea de que este acuerdo Se
dará autoridad a la OMS son simplemente
noticias falsas simple fake news
A qué se refiere aquí el director de la
OMS básicamente la preocupación de
varios países de que este tipo de
tratados interfiera en sus decisiones
nacionales básicamente de estas
lecciones que mencionaba de la pandemia
está sobre todo lo que se debate el
acceso a los productos médicos vacunas
tratamientos todo lo que pueda ayudar a
mantener cualquier brote pandémico bajo
control y que sabemos que durante la
pandemia de covid-19 quedó en manos de
muy pocos Especialmente cuando hablamos
de las vacunas por supuesto es una
conversación compleja porque los países
con más recursos tienen mucha reticencia
aceptar este tipo de tratados porque
basan gran parte de su éxito de
vacunación y de control de la pandemia o
relativo éxito en a poder haber vacunado
muy deprisa cosa que hicieron pues
comprando la gran mayoría de insumos de
vacunas que había contra el covid 19 y
lo que busca el tratado en cambios
romper con esta dinámica de quienes
tienen más recursos compran todo y luego
a los países con menos recursos llegan
las vacunas o los tratamientos en
formato de donaciones La idea es que
todos todos los países puedan acceder de
forma igualitaria a estos a estos
mecanismos entonces bueno La idea es que
se apruebe dentro de un año en la
siguiente asamblea Pues esperemos que sí
pero Esto va en contra de los intereses
económicos de las grandes farmacéuticas
Así que veremos si prima al final el
interés sobre la salud pública pues mire
Muchísimas gracias mar gracias Ángela